wo ist dein weg
[Musik]
danke das war gut du bist ein
naturtalent ja letzte woche konnte es
noch gar nicht fahrrad fahren und das
war richtig gut
toll danke das macht spaß selber warum
warum wollen deine eltern nicht dass wir
uns sehen was nein dass sie wollen nicht
dass ich mich alleine mit männern treffe
du bist so erwachsen du kannst machen
was du willst
bei uns kann ich als frau nicht einfach
so jemanden treffen das geht nicht
als meine eltern jung waren durften sie
sich auch nicht sehen aber heute ich
komme mit meinen eltern auch nicht
zurecht wieso auch ich liebe meine
eltern aber in syrien hat der mann bis
heute in einigen traditionellen familien
andere pflichten als die frau die frau
zum beispiel aufgaben im haushalt der
mann geht arbeiten meine familie
erwartet von mir dass ich unsere
tradition respektiere neuer hast du
dieses mal die wahrheit gesagt wissen
deine eltern wo du bist
los mach mal
[Musik]
[Applaus]